leslie bonjour alors dites-nous tout que
sont ces timbres de l'égalité eh bien
ces timbres doivent refléter l'injuste
réalité qui ne devrait pas exister
c'est avec cette phrase que la campagne
a été lancée par correos la post
espagnol alors cette initiative a été
menée en partenariat avec l ong sos
racisme et avec un rappeur qui milite
contre le racisme
alors c'est une série de quatre timbres
est là pour objectif de sensibiliser sur
l'inégalité sociale défendre la liberté
et l'égalité des droits dans une vidéo
promotionnelle
il est expliqué je cite qu'il y a des
personnes qui pensent que la valeur d'un
être humain dépend de la couleur de peau
et pour illustrer les initiateurs de
cette campagne ont donc décidé que les
timbres n'est pas le même prix donc j'ai
pris vont de 1 euro 60 à 60 centimes et
la poste souhaite fassi que chaque
lettre envoyée reflètent l'inégalité
créé par le racisme alors elle veut
surtout rappelé que la valeur d'une
personne ne dépend pas de la couleur de
cook
alors la sortie de ces timbres coïncidé
avec le premier anniversaire du meurtre
de george fail et finalement c'est parle
sont-ils accusé de véhiculer un message
raciste alors plus un timbre et de
couleur claire et plus et coûte cher
ainsi de nombreuses voix accusent la
campagne au final de véhicules et donc
un message racisme car pour certains
cette différence de prix entre les
couleurs laisse à penser qu'un timbre
plus clair a plus de valeur qu'un timbre
foncé sur les réseaux sociaux les
utilisateurs s'indigne il indique qu on
peut ne pas faire la différence entre
les racistes et anti racistes et des
activistes ont signalé qu'au final il ya
une grande contradiction qu'il aurait
fallu que les timbres et tous le même
prix qu pour expliquer que tout le monde
a la même valeur
il ya également des divergences ce sens
même des sceaux est racisme ou des
membres explique que finalement c'est le
message contraire à celui souhaité qui a
été véhiculé et d'autres voix vont même
plus loin en disant que ça pourrait
jouer en faveur du parti d'extrême
droite de vox qui est la troisième force
politique d'espagne depuis les élections
générales de 2009 merci beaucoup leslie
pour ces précisions leslie singla en
direct de barcelone